[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de Parlement
Hebdo les temps forts à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat revue et commenté
par notre invité et on accueille
aujourd'hui Sophie prima bonjour
sénatrice les républicains des Yvelines
et présidente de la commission des
affaires économiques du Sénat il y a
beaucoup d'actualité pour vous Sophie
prima puisque cette semaine Elisabeth
borne a donc lancé le chantier des
retraites la réforme prévoit notamment
de reculer l'âge légal de départ à 64
ans en 2030 et d'allonger la durée de
cotisation la bataille au Parlement et
dans la rue est annoncé
les députés ont donné leur feu vert au
projet de loi ENR le texte porte sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
il a été adopté avec notamment les voix
des socialistes
et puis au Sénat un projet de loi sur le
nucléaire à l'ordre du jour il prévoit
d'accélérer la construction de réacteurs
promesse d'Emmanuel Macron audition de
la ministre à suivre la réforme des
retraites a donc été présenté cette
semaine par la première ministre
Elisabeth borne une réforme qui prévoit
un report de l'âge légal de départ à 64
ans mais également des mesures sociales
comme la retraite minimale pour les
carrières complètes à hauteur de 85% du
SMIC alors cette réforme des retraites
elle plaît au parlementaire de droite et
à gauche la mobilisation sociale
s'organise derrière les syndicats
Jonathan du priez
c'est la mesure la plus emblématique
mais aussi la plus polémique de la
réforme des retraites l'exécutif a opté
pour un report progressif de l'âge légal
de départ à 64 ans et qui prendra effet
d'ici à 2030 à compter du premier
septembre l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite sera relevé progressivement de
trois mois par an pour atteindre 64 ans
en 2030 le gouvernement a aussi décidé
de jouer sur d'autres paramètres comme
la durée de cotisation qu'il entend
allongée à 43 à nuités d'ici à 2027
l'exécutive vant une réforme permettant
de garantir l'équilibre financier du
système et qui se veut aussi plus juste
pour les Français meilleur pris en
compte des carrières longues ou hachées
de la pénibilité du travail le
gouvernement veut aussi revaloriser les
pensions minimum à hauteur de 85% du
SMIC s'il exécutive vende des avancées
les syndicats font déjà affront commun
pour bloquer une réforme juger injustée
brutale Laurent Berger secrétaire
général de la CFDT s'y oppose totalement
pour moi c'est toujours non pour la CFDT
c'est toujours non pour l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales de ce pays
c'est non 64 ans c'est non pourquoi
parce que cette réforme qu'on qualifie
d'ailleurs de réforme des retraites
c'est davantage d'une réforme des
finances publiques c'est davantage une
réforme d'équilibre financier sur le
seul dos des travailleurs sur le plan
politique le gouvernement multiplie les
appels du pied à la droite les LR Ford
leurs 62 députés seront incontournables
pour faire adopter la réforme réforme
qu'ils appellent de leurs vœux depuis
des années qu'en réalité c'est pas nous
qu'allons voter la réforme si on la vote
du gouvernement c'est le gouvernement de
l'anamélisabeth borne qui propose à sa
propre majorité de voter la réforme que
nous avons ici en réalité rédigé puis
voté depuis au moins quatre ans à gauche
la Nupe s’aligne sur la position des
syndicats et rejette en bloc la réforme
souhaitée par le gouvernement regardez
bien les deux ans sauf sous certaines
conditions supplémentaires c'est pour
tout le monde
l'accélération du nombre de de
cotisations là aussi c'est pour tout le
monde c'est une mesure on peut tourner
le truc dans tous les sens c'est un
impôt sur les pauvres c'est un impôt sur
la vie sur la vie des gens il y a des
gens qui ont des vies difficiles la
bataille pour les retraites et désormais
lancée et la mobilisation de la rue
s'organise premier grand test le 19
janvier les 8 principaux syndicats
appellent à une journée de grève dans
tout le pays Sophie prima cette réforme
des retraites présentées par le
gouvernement c'est une réforme de la
droite c'est une victoire pour vous je
sais pas si c'est une victoire pour nous
mais c'est une victoire pour les
retraites c'est une victoire pour le
système de répartition tel qu'il existe
en France depuis très très longtemps et
qui garantit à l'ensemble des salariés
une retraite qui soit une retraite la
plus digne possible et en tout cas la
plus préservée possible donc ce qui est
fait là c'est ce que la droite en effet
réclame depuis maintenant plusieurs
années qu'on avait commencé à faire en
2010 où je suis rentrée à l'Assemblée
nationale comme député au moment de la
Réforme verte portée par François Fillon
et donc nous sommes responsables par
rapport à un système de retraite faut
préserver et faire perdurer donc la
responsabilité elle est là elle est pas
dans des déclarations je vois monsieur
Boris Vallot qui prend des raccourcis
qui sont des raccourcis populistes et
non responsables donc je crois que c'est
très réforme elle est elle est
indispensable et comme l'a dit Bruno
Retailleau dans votre dans votre sujet
c'est une réforme que nous votons au
Sénat depuis plusieurs années sur les
grands principes et donc nous sommes
plutôt satisfaits de voir que le
gouvernement c'est enfin rangé après
l'épisode de le voir Beyrout pietrazeki
etc enfin on arrive à une réforme des
retraites alors on vous avait obtenu
beaucoup de choses vous parlementaire de
droite comme vous le dites est-ce que
vous avez malgré tout des lignes rouges
qui persistent sur cette réforme oui je
pense qu'on est d'accord globalement
vous avez vu à la fois Bruno retaillodie
Olivier Marleix venir discuter à
Matignon nous avons encore des avancées
sociales à obtenir notamment je crois
qu'il y a un début d'accord sur la
revalorisation des petite retraite nous
souhaitons que cette disposition
s'applique non pas aux nouveaux
retraités qui vont arriver mais à
l'ensemble des retraités qui sont
concernés
ça le sera ça sera dans les lignes
rouges de la droite en tout cas vraiment
c'est un souhait que nous exerçons puis
ensuite nous avons des dispositions que
nous allons améliorer j'ai eu cette
discussion acronyme qui sera le
rapporteur au Sénat hier soir nous avons
peut-être des pentes de montée en
puissance que nous allons peut-être
renégocier je pense que c'est des
éléments qui seront de nature aussi dans
le dialogue avec les syndicats à
apporter des améliorations sociales à la
voix et puis nous avons une disposition
au Sénat à quelle nous tenons beaucoup
qui est une avancée pour nous sociale
très importante notamment pour le monde
du handicap qui est la possibilité quand
vous avez un enfant handicapé de faire
une réversion en fait de la retraite des
parents vers les enfants handicapés vous
savez que c'est un sujet quand vous avez
un enfant handicapé de savoir quel est
son avenir et comment il va aborder son
avenir donc nous tenons beaucoup à cette
à cette réforme sociale quand vous dites
qu'il faut modifier améliorer les pentes
de montée en puissance concrètement
qu'est-ce que ça voudrait dire voilà
aller plus doucement dans dans
la pente vous savez des trois mois
supplémentaires par année etc je pense
que là il y a matière à négociation avec
le gouvernement pour améliorer adoucir
j'allais dire cette pente ça voudrait
dire qu'on pourrait arriver à 64 ans
plus tard après 2003 peut-être un petit
peu plus tard donc ça ça sera dans les
objets de négociation entre d'abord la
première discussion qui aura peut-être
lieu à l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'on
comprend pas bien comment tout ça va se
discuter à l'Assemblée nationale
puisqu'il y a des groupes politiques ont
annoncé un nom de considérable
d'amendements pour bloquer la loi donc
peut-être que la discussion en réalité
elle se fera au Sénat en tout cas la
réforme telle qu'elle a été présentée
dans ces grandes lignes semblerait faire
certains perdants et notamment les
grands perdants seraient ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt et qui devrait
cotiser jusqu'à 44 ans est-ce que vous
admettez ça non
ça fait partie des choses sur lesquelles
on va travailler avec René Paul Savary
et qu'on va travailler avec le
gouvernement en disant il faut protéger
évidemment tous les dispositifs de
carrière longue et l'heure de questions
que des gens qui ont commencé à
travailler actuellement voilà donc ça
c'est des agents voilà ce sont des
ajustements voilà ce sont voilà des cas
particuliers d'ajustements qui enfin il
y a un principe général sur lequel on
est d'accord et puis ensuite il y a des
cas particuliers qui ne manqueront pas
de nous remonter d'ici la discussion au
Sénat et sur lequel nous proposerons des
des solutions alors la mobilisation
sociale contre cette réforme et lancer
avec les syndicats les parties de gauche
jeudi prochain s'annonce comme un jeudi
noir dans la rue est-ce que vous
craignez que la France soit bloquée je
pense que c'est c'est une crainte que
nous avons tous que nous partageons tous
j'allais dire de droit de gauche monde
économique monde civil monde politique
c'est le blocage de la ruche je pense
qu'on sort de trois années horribles
entre covid crise sanitaire
crise sociale etc enfin je pense qu'on
et puis anxiété dû aussi au contexte
international etc je pense que nous
redoutons effectivement à blocage du
pays ça ne serait pas responsable
globalement pour quelques travailleurs
que ce soit quelques salariés que ce
soit j'entends des discriminations
salariés modeste cadre etc je pense que
notre pays dans une situation difficile
qu'elle est dans une situation sensible
au niveau économique par la crise
énergétique je crois qu'il faut être
responsable et j'ai presque de la peine
de voir Laurent Berger dans des postures
syndicales dures alors qu'on est
d'habitude dans un dialogue avec lui si
c'est pas le cas si cette opposition se
développe persiste est-ce que vous
admettez l'idée de de concession moi je
pense je pense que la discussion au
Sénat le traitement des points que vous
que vous souleviez les avancées sociales
que nous pourrions obtenir au Sénat sont
des éléments qui sont de nature dans un
dialogue avec les syndicats à arriver à
trouver une solution il faut que tout le
monde soit responsable autour de la
table on aura le temps de reparler de
cette bataille qui a annoncé début
février à l'Assemblée avec la
présentation d'un projet de loi sur les
retraites c'est voter les députés ont
donc adopté cette semaine le projet de
loi qui accélère le développement des
énergies renouvelables le gouvernement a
pu compter sur les voies de la gauche
pour faire passer son texte malgré un
petit bug informatique à la fin de la
séance
compte-rendu avec Stéphanie Despierre
à l'Assemblée commence dans un éclat de
rire
j'ai un problème en face
et à gauche
et par un couac le système électronique
de votre ne fonctionne plus et ce 3 fois
de suite il faudra donc sortir les bons
vieux bulletins papier pour voter avec 3
heures de retard finalement l'assemblée
dit oui à l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables un premier succès pour le
gouvernement soutenu par les centristes
de lot et une fois n'est pas coutume par
les socialistes pourtant dans
l'opposition il y a pas de pire
opposition que celle qui soit dans une
sorte de posture permanente de dire non
parce que
si à mon avis le ciel est bleu il faut
dire qu'il est bleu s'il est gris et
qu'il y a des gros nuages noirs comme
avec des retraites il faut le dire
également et dénoncé mais pour les vers
le ciel est trop gris moins d'une heure
avant le vote la ministre tentait encore
une fois de les convaincre de voter sa
loi en matière d'action climatique il y
a ceux qui parlent et ceux qui agissent
vous avez encore la possibilité d'être
dans cette deuxième catégorie en votant
le projet de loi d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables
les écologistes s'abstiennent cardistie
il n'y a pas que le titre de la loi qui
compte ça voudrait dire que finalement
parce qu'il y a un titre qui s'appelle
accès à les énergies renouvelables les
écologistes sont pour non c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe il faut que le
texte accélère réellement et là
aujourd'hui il accélère pas il faut pas
dire qu'il freine ils freinent pas mais
c'est pas un bon texte la France
insoumise et les communistes ont
carrément voté contre tout comme les
républicains et leur rassemblement
national vend debout contre le
développement des éoliennes nous sommes
de ceux qui disent non de ceux qui
refusent de massacrer nos campagnes et
notre patrimoine de ceux qui refusent de
détruire notre modèle électrique
performant de ceux qui n'abandonnent pas
les intérêts nationaux de ceux qui ne
sacrifient pas la biodiversité nos
paysages ont des délires idéologiques le
Sénat a adopté ce projet de loi en fin
d'année mais dans une version différente
de l'Assemblée députée et sénateurs se
retrouvent donc le 24 janvier pour
chercher un accord
voilà alors Sophie prima vous serez donc
dans cette commission mix paritaire qui
réunit député sénateur pour espérer
trouver un texte de compromis néanmoins
il faudra satisfaire un peu tout le
monde et notamment les socialistes qui
ont donné leur voix au texte est-ce que
c'est pas un peu mission impossible tout
de même non je ne pense pas que ce soit
mission impossible je veux dire en
préalable que le Sénat a largement voté
puisqu'en fait d'abord il y a quelque
chose qui m'agace sur ce texte-là c'est
ce texte ne s'appelle pas le texte sur
les éoliennes et donc le rassemblement
national enfin des positions extrêmes
ils s'appellent énergies renouvelable et
dans les énergies renouvelables le Sénat
était très très attentif pour y mettre
toutes les énergies renouvelables et on
a des dispositions sur
l'hydroélectricité sur la biomasse sur
le biogaz sur le fond
l'essentiel du texte donc en fait toute
la difficulté repose sur le fait que ce
n'est pas un texte sur les éoliennes
simplement sur les éoliennes voilà donc
nous le Sénat on a une ligne rouge et
une posture qui est de donner la main
aux élus locaux donc tout ce que vous
entendez sur les éoliennes ou pas
défiguré tout ça est à la main des élus
les mers notamment les mers pas que les
mers les EPCI les scottes etc et c'est
une réflexion territoriale qui doit
remonter vers en terme de planification
pour déterminer des zones qui sont des
zones prioritaires d'installation des
énergies renouvelables des énergies
renouvelables voilà avec des
possibilités pour les mères de dire je
veux ça je veux pas ça et si je veux des
éoliennes je veux pas qu'elle soit plus
de telle hauteur je veux pas etc donc
véritablement nous on fait confiance au
territoire à la fois pour être
responsable dans le fait qu'il faut des
énergies renouvelables en complément du
nucléaire pour arriver à satisfaire les
besoins en électricité de notre pays et
on fait confiance aux maires donc c'est
vraiment ça notre ligne rouge à nous et
donc le texte issu de l'Assemblée
nationale donne toujours la main Homer
pour définir les zones prioritaires pour
les projets d'énergie renouvelables donc
normalement il devrait y avoir un accord
entre sénateurs et députés sur une
version commune à améliorer parce que
sur les zones qui ne sont pas
prioritaires on peut quand même faire
des énergies renouvelables et là il faut
aussi que le meilleur garde la
possibilité de dire oui ou de dire non
donc il y a encore un accompagnement il
y a encore quelques informations à bien
cadrer à bien détailler mais voilà on
est on est moi j'ai confiance je pense
qu'on va pouvoir trouver un accord Agnès
panière une hacher la ministre craint
des postures politiques de la droite
dans ce débat ce qu'elle a raison ça
sera pas mes postures politiques enfin
moi je avec le président Longeot qui est
président de la Commission de du
développement durable on est on est
co-responsable de ce texte et on n'a pas
l'habitude d'avoir des postures
politiques on est là sur une ligne ou
l'intérêt de la France mais aussi
l'intérêt j'allais dire territorial
l'acceptabilité des énergies
renouvelables est un point politique
important moi j'essaye d'éviter les
postures politiques parce que voilà je
trouve que c'est pas l'intérêt de la
faute donc accord en vue on va essayer
il y a quelques points moi ils ont
retiré quelques informations notamment
la gauche d'ailleurs à retirer et les
écologistes ont retiré quelques
dispositions sur les Draux électricité
moi j'y tiens beaucoup il y a des
dispositions aussi sur le ce qu'on
appelle le partage de la valeur
c'est-à-dire que partir du moment où les
territoires donnent leur accord pour
avoir des zones d'accélération des
énergies renouvelables il faut qu'ils en
ait un bénéfice moi je pense que la
collectivité doit en être bénéficiaire
donc on a encore quelques petits points
à toper avec le gouvernement pour
trouver un accord et puis Sophie prima
la semaine prochaine au Sénat un autre
texte énergétique sera débattu dans
l'hémicycle c'est le projet de loi qui
accélère la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires alors on le
rappelle dans la campagne présidentielle
Emmanuel Macron a promis au moins la
construction de six nouveaux réacteurs
EPR 2 ce projet de loi il simplifie les
procédures administratives et il arrive
aussi six mois avant un texte plus
politique sur l'énergie ce sera la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
qui doit définir par exemple la place du
nucléaire dans notre mix énergétique et
pour certains sénateurs il faut d'abord
avoir ce débat politique avant de
prévoir l'accélération de la
construction va écouter un échange entre
le sénateur communiste Fabien gay et la
ministre de la transition énergétique
pourquoi ce projet de loi maintenant
madame la ministre parce que pour le
coup vous avez raison le nucléaire c'est
du temps long 15 20 25 ans de
construction 40 60 ans d'exploitation
vous avez dit qu'il y a tout un tas de
questions qui seront dans la PPE et vous
commencez à y répondre parce que vous
êtes obligé de faire la politique parce
que c'est un texte extrêmement technique
mais en même temps on veut faire de la
politique
la ce texte il est important pour parce
que en fait on a analysé la conduite du
projet de nouvelles centrales nucléaires
en faisant un rétroplanning et donc le
dossier administratif et les dossiers de
permis de construire doivent être
adaptés dès maintenant
si on veut effectivement livrer des
réacteurs nucléaires dans 15 ans là
aussi
c'est
ce sont des dossiers qui prennent
plusieurs années ce projet de loi est
permis de gagner plusieurs années et la
coulé du premier béton si on veut tenir
cet objectif de couler du premier béton
à 5 ans ça suppose que ce projet de loi
soit adopté avant la fin du premier
semestre Sophie prima la majorité de
droite du Sénat devrait voter ce projet
de loi qui accélère la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs alors je pense qu'on
va le voter avec des modifications qu'on
a apportées en commission cette semaine
mais je partage la vie de Fabien gay
c'est à dire que on ne cesse de répéter
et on l'a fait sur le texte des ENR des
énergies renouvelables on ne cesse de
répéter qu'on les GIF faire mal et dans
le mauvais sens il faut d'abord donner
une vision d'abord donner un chemin et
ensuite se donner les moyens d'y arriver
donc on est là dans une espèce de
précipitation qui est une précipitation
qui ressemble à une précipitation
politique vous voyez la réponse d'Agnès
panier rue Nachet elle demande pas de
sel quand même bien on veut couler le
premier béton avant la fin du
quinquennat enfin bon donc c'est on est
dans les annonces politiques et on n'est
pas dans une stratégie politique et ça
ça aussi c'est de la politique
politicienne et c'est pas de la
politique visionnaire pour notre pays
donc on est très en retard sur le
nucléaire vous savez que les
tergiversations sur le nucléaire elles
ont été énormes nous on dit simplement
dans ce texte de loi on n'a pas encore
mis fin au décret qui arrête
l'arrêt des 12 des 12 centrales
nucléaires des 12 réacteurs nucléaires
on n'a pas mis fin au 50% maximum
d'énergie nucléaire dans le mix français
en 2035 donc c'est contradictoire avec
ce texte là donc on est obligé de on est
obligé d'enlever ces dispositions
la relance du nucléaire dans dans
l'objet de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qu'on nous
annonce à la au mois de juin au mois
d'autres échos me dit qu'on sera plutôt
du côté de l'automne sur cette
informations plus réelle de l'énergie le
débat que l'on voit aura lieu en automne
peut-être ou alors si la lieu au mois de
juillet ce serait déçu pour les Français
et des suit aussi pour le Parlement
parce que c'est pas quand même on a
l'habitude de nous faire les les lois
sur l'énergie ou en plein mois de
juillet je trouve que c'est pas très
respectueux du voilà du débat
parlementaire et des Français parce que
c'est un sujet qui est éminemment
important on le voit dans la crise
énergétique si on est dans cette
situation aujourd'hui c'est bien parce
que la vision depuis 10 ans est pas la
bonne a pas déterminer la bonne
direction donc ce sera important dans ce
débat la semaine prochaine de supprimer
cet objectif de 50% de nucléaire pas
plus en 2035 c'est presque une
coordination juridique de l'accélération
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas d'un côté
dire on fait de l'accélération technique
mécanique des procédures pour installer
des centrales nucléaires tout en disant
en même temps on veut pas plus de 50% en
2035 c'est tout à fait contradictoire si
on le fait pas il y a un hiatus
juridique
alors il y a eu un autre sujet qui était
débattu cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale la question de l'uniforme à
l'école le rassemblement national a
déposé une proposition de loi pour le
rendre obligatoire c'était dans le cadre
de sa journée d'initiative parlementaire
réservé le texte a été rejeté en séance
publique écoutez Marine Le Pen lors de
ce débat extrait
souhaitons pour les élèves c'est qu'avec
la tenue uniforme portée dans les écoles
il n'y ait ni discrimination sociale ni
niveau de fortune ni religion qu'il n'y
ait que des élèves
alors voilà la proposition de loi a donc
été rejetée mais Brigitte Macron dit oui
à l'uniforme la droite aussi la majorité
présidentielle travaille même
travaillerait sur une proposition de loi
est-ce que pour vous imposer l'uniforme
Sophie prima va permettre de régler
comme par magie tous les problèmes de
l'école est-ce que c'est là la priorité
alors évidemment non évidemment le
problème de l'école est beaucoup plus
profond et beaucoup plus compliqué et
d'ailleurs la commission de l'éducation
au Sénat est en train d'entamer un
travail voilà pour pouvoir proposer des
choses sur l'école
alors après premièrement je voudrais
dire que je déteste le mot d'uniforme
voilà parce que c'est extrêmement
conservateur ça fait appel à à des
notions qui n'ont rien à faire avec
l'école on n'est pas à l'armée on n'est
pas en 1912 enfin bref ce document il
est très mal choisi je pense qu'il faut
dire tenue vestimentaire moi je suis
j'étais
un peu comme vous dubitatif sur ce texte
de loi etc je pense qu'on est arrivé
aujourd'hui dans une situation où
d'abord il faut il faut aider les
proviseurs de collège il faut aider les
proviseurs parce que ils savent plus
entre le t-shirt qui arrive là le
pantalon qui arrive en dessous les
fesses les signes les signes religieux
etc tout ça est trop compliqué moi j'ai
bien l'histoire d'une tenue d'abord
parce que je trouve que c'est
collaboratif entre guillemets on peut
imaginer que dans chaque établissement
il y a un groupe fait avec des parents
des élèves des profs qui décident c'est
quoi une tenue c'est un jean sweat on le
floque on le flotte pas etc j'aime bien
l'idée d'appartenance aussi
d'appartenance à une communauté
éducative je trouve que ça c'est
intéressant et puis ça vient aider les
proviseurs dans cette espèce de police
du vêtement qu'on essaie d'installer
qu'on n'arrive pas à installer ça peut
régler les problèmes d'attente la
laïcité on le voit avec le port de
vêtements religieux d'inspiration
islamique je pense que c'est aussi une
réponse à ça parmi les sujets qui sont
traités par cette tenue vestimentaire
mais moi j'aime bien m'appuyer sur cette
histoire d'appartenance parce que je
trouve que dans une société qui est par
plein de choses dont les les éléments
religieux de se dire qu'on appartient à
une communauté éducative tous ensemble
c'est assez intéressant comme concept et
bien on va terminer cette émission en
regardant ce qui attend député et
sénateurs la semaine prochaine c'est
l'agenda
[Musique]
et à l'agenda du Sénat mardi prochain ce
sera donc le début du débat en séance
sur le projet de loi qui accélère la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires et puis en commission les
sénateurs vont commencer à examiner le
projet de loi sur les jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 avec notamment beaucoup de
questions sur la sécurité de l'événement
et à l'Assemblée nationale des députés
examineront un texte qui vise à
sécuriser l'approvisionnement des
Français en produits de grande
consommation dans ce contexte de crise
alimentaire l'assemblée discutera aussi
de la proposition de loi venue du Sénat
pour créer une aide universelle
d'urgence pour les victimes de violence
conjugales alors on va peut-être vous
poser une question puisqu'on parle de
cette proposition de loi cette semaine à
l'Assemblée nationale Adrien castain
katenas pardon a fait son retour le
député a été condamné à quatre mois de
prison avec sursis pour des violences à
l'encontre de son épouse est-ce que ce
retour d'Adrien cadenas à l'Assemblée
vous dérange Sophie prima ce qui me
dérange c'est le manque de cohérence
d'une d'une parole publique et politique
voilà quand on sait les positions à la
fois du groupe LFI à la fois de de
Monsieur catenans en séance sur ces
sujets là des positions fermes des
positions fortes des positions même
agressives et qu'on voit son propre
comportement je pense que ça pose la
question de la cohérence alors qui
reviennent à l'Assemblée oui évidemment
c'est un peu choquant mais c'est une
question pour lui de conscience
personnelle son groupe là exclu lui a
demandé de parler intégrer le groupe
c'est le minimum qui pouvait faire moi
je me dis que au moins il aurait pu
démissionner même s'il veut se
représenter devant ses électeurs c'est
peut-être à ses électeurs de décider
s'il doit retourner à l'Assemblée ou pas
mais je pense que c'est vraiment une
question de conscience personnelle et de
cohérence politique les députés de la
majorité présidentielle ont annoncé
qu'ils allaient déposer une proposition
de loi pour prévoir une peine
obligatoire d'inel éligibilité pour tous
les élus condamnés pour violences
conjugales est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à un tel texte oui je n'aime
pas non plus la légiférer sous l'effet
de tout le temps de
de l'émotion et le jour même du coup
Adrien
on se côtoie depuis longtemps dans les
Yvelines donc je sais qu'elle est très
très friande de coups politiques comme
ça maintenant sur le fond pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas parce que l'incohérence est
tellement forte que elle peut mériter
effectivement une peine d'inéligibilité
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup Sophie prima d'avoir été notre
premier invité de l'année pour ce numéro
de Parlement Hebdo bonne année et merci
à tous de l'avoir suivi et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine même heure
même lieu pour ne rien rater les
incontournables du Parlement ciao ciao
[Musique]